we're just saying like what it looks so
somewhat else to have people been
correcting a lot is you know how I say
slaps for everything usually it's max
I'm like bro there's not a [ __ ] rule
I could say slap if you want it's
because it's a Bay Area thing right so
yeah it takes a lingo very thank you
it's for some reason people in the Bay
are so particular about that you know
I'm from Sacramento right so like I
understand what they mean but it's it a
big [ __ ] deal
okay my bro I've just said slaps for
everything I never knew it was like a
term in the Bayeux this [ __ ] slaps girl
this [ __ ] really does slap on it it's
like excuse me or say smack particular
about that should they want people to
understand that when it comes from food
is SH Max and then when it comes for
music it's always slap but you don't use
it for anything else and if you do it's
heresy and I might use it for both I
don't say smacks yeah I don't do that
laughs for every it's not as fun to say
Bob I guess my thing is I guess people
are so Cala whatever you do different
that's all
yeah it is whatever bro what a weird
thing they're like get upset about I'll
be there I'm sad but just like you know
that shit's max yeah and it's a slap see
that sounds weird I don't want to go I
don't like that you say all the like
gunk builds up in like you drip and [ __ ]
I trying to drip Oh shouting I got
shoutouts to [ __ ] alien beef jerky
for the the racist funny about that [ __ ]
though I'm not saying that I am the
catalyst or the source for that she's
the catalyst so I got a message from a
friend of mine who who told me about his
personal friend that contacted this is
this is a really famous beef jerky spot
that everybody stops by when they drive
to Vegas right so that long three-hour
drive everybody stops by that spot even
I know that place they are really great
everybody knows that even I do I've been
to Vegas once I think and they know
about that right very unique beef jerky
you know really good yeah it's an
immigrant Mexican family that owns it so
one of our friends
she basically emailed them I don't know
exactly what she does but you know it
was solicit them for some business or
whatever right and he responds back that
we don't not to nothing exact quotes but
basically saying that he doesn't want
anything to do with any Orientals delete
my email or whatever blah blah blah blah
yeah
and so people's very aggressive it was
very clear business email yeah and so
she was like what the [ __ ] did she and
what in the email that she sent out did
she say that she wasn't worried well her
picture is there okay
he thought it is yes I see cuz I don't
[ __ ] with gooks there it is and so she
have to say I don't say that well uh a
buddy of mine message that to me and
he's like you know what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] about it was like yo can you do
something about this and at first like I
don't I don't really like doing this and
then I kind of sat on it and I'm like
it's problematic dude okay this is
[ __ ] up yes you know so I did a little
light tweet the the tweets gone now by
the way I deleted that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was getting a lot of crazy matter I'm
the king of screenshots you should
notice a DM Alex getting up there and
likes and retweets a little faster than
I expected I'm like okay well they
learned their lesson because after I
posted that about an hour later they had
like I don't on their Yelp because I
actually hyperlinked their Yelp as well
it got I don't know 200 like one-star
reviews in like an hour or something I'm
like cool they learned their lesson
nothing is gonna happen after this lo
and behold that day it's everywhere dude
like I blew the [ __ ] up well that's what
you kind of deserve though talking
talking like that what for what that
purr and then their excuse was kind of
weak they said like he's a he's a
Mexican immigrant has nothing to do with
email he his Lenten the language barrier
but I was like dog this fool has been
and then people were also saying that
they've been in business for like 23
years yeah yeah they and and they
exactly they were met with all oriental
they were alone and they were also
saying that this is like they've done
stuff like this before
oh he's not supposed to be making those
messages like yeah he's not the one in
charge so so who the [ __ ] no password
then what the hell so then that's even
crazier came up to one of his kids he's
like hey let me see they up
I just need to buy something from Amazon
you know what that reminds me of now
actually something like that kind of
happened in the powerlifting world there
was a big meet that always goes on and
it's one of the meats were like the big
lifters go because you can make a lot of
money off of this meat I forget the
exact name of the meat but it was held
in a gym in San Diego right so they
opened up like I do this meat called the
boss of bosses it's at a gym in Mountain
View you might know where that's at
right Mountain View it's owned by a guy
a big power lifter named dan green he
owns the gym right so man looks like a
refrigerator you know yeah yeah so yeah
so he holds that me right so I do that
one so there's another meat like that
really big they open it up at bosses
they do one day where it's like Amateur
you would say and then the other days
professional or like you don't have to
qualify for this day but if you're gonna
do this day after qualify right so same
with this other meat they did something
like that where you have to qualify for
this meat so this one girl emails the
meat director who owns the gym her
numbers and stuff like that like oh this
is my numbers luh basically she
qualified for the meat or some [ __ ] like
that right heard the response back from
that girl was like why the [ __ ] are you
like wasting my time with this [ __ ]
but these weak-ass numbers like saying
some [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] right
so that girl screenshotted it and posted
it on Instagram and everybody just
repost repost me post repost repost it
got all the way back around to the
Federation that we like I compete in
USPA and they actually like wiped her
off she's not allowed to hold the meats
anymore that Mika why did she why did
she go off like that I don't I don't I
don't fully remember what her excuse was
I think she was like she was emotional
or that type of [ __ ] like that was the
thing she was like the girl was like a
cop out there I was like you told us to
email you our numbers and stuff that's
exactly what I did yeah and her response
I don't remember word for word aside
what am I supposed to do with these
weak-ass [ __ ] I was like funny dawg hang
you all you do is just be like sorry
this this hypertensive yeah this still
doesn't meet the requirements that
really for the competition or the mall
want to see their stuff what a great
roast though hilarious but second of all
like these weekend
Jass somebody who was a weightlifter and
I heard that I think I would cry I'd
quit and second of all [ __ ] me right you
get emotional about their numbers and
their calves calves bro I don't know
what that's like cuz your boy got great
calves I know me too
he's talking about me oh you're so
fragile little weak bro I sometimes want
to crush you and boy I get bigger I do
don't try and man it's all good I'm
waiting for Mike my steroids in the
[ __ ] mail this guy's got a cycle time
shit's fun hey don't say everybody think
I sell [ __ ] bro I got ID on this fool
I'm sorry guys
that's fine no oh yeah oh yeah we got
all these G's arms do you know like that
should do you here homie we got dragon
steroids bro yeah you want scale no yeah
no it's it's crazy
steroids are crazy too I would let me
tell you something if you guys ever yeah
buff ever just know that I was on
steroids there's absolutely no way
they're gonna we're gonna hop on a cycle
to God man I just I feel like oh no
we're not doing wouldn't you wouldn't
broke because that's how I was so I did
a I did a cycle of tests right and
that's how kind of how I always was I
was I was always so nervous are you
admitting to steroids right now I don't
care bro I don't understand I don't know
why people lie about this [ __ ] dude it's
like I feel bad for like people that are
trying to come up in like say you're
trying to learn Fitness and stuffing you
show this person and they're like all
ripped and [ __ ] in there lying though
I'm all natural dude that's the problem
with a lot of people who kind of here's
the thing about the fitness interested a
lot of people don't know so much money
in this [ __ ] yeah oh well dick ulis
amount there's a reason why people are